so we we're looking at the hearing that
took place yesterday senate hearing with
dr anthony fauci and cdc director
rachelle wolensky about the pandemic uh
rand paul
and dr fauci's confrontation we already
looked at the funniest moment is that
after republican senator roger marshall
said all sorts of stupid things and
asked really dumb questions dr fauci was
caught on it's being called a hot mic dr
fauci may have known that the mic was on
i mean who knows maybe he did this on
purpose
saying what a [ __ ] followed by jesus
christ i i just absolutely love this
let's take a look the clip going viral
instantly
totally incorrect we look forward to
reviewing it senator marshall dr fauci
has answered you to his public
information and he's happy to give it to
you if you would ask senator moran
jesus christ
what a [ __ ] it is an exasperated dr
anthony fauci and you know what roger
marshall is a [ __ ] he
without any [ __ ] is too light a term to
apply to him here's some of roger
marshall's questioning
dr fauci according to forbes
you have an annual salary in 2020 was
434 thousand dollars
you oversee over 5 billion they actually
put up like a blown up fake novelty
check
this is about the pandemic i thought
wars and federal research grants
as the highest paid employee in the
entire federal government
yes or no would you be willing to submit
to congress and the public a financial
disclosure that includes your past and
current investments after all your
colleague dr wilinski and every member
of congress submits a financial
disclosure that includes their
investments
now here's a mic off moment then he
turns his mic
i on understand why you're asking me
that question my financial disclosure
is public knowledge and has been so
for the last 37 years or so of 35 years
the reason he's asking it even though
the financial disclosures are already
public is he wants brownie points from
the right for doing it in a hearing
big tech giants are doing an incredible
job of keeping it from being public uh
we'll continue to look for it where
would we find it
all you have to do is ask for it
uh you're so misinformed it's
extraordinary why am i my most important
this is a huge issue wouldn't you agree
with me that that you have a you see
things before members of congress would
see him so that there's a an air of
appearance that that maybe some
shenanigans are going on you know
there's an air of appearance that some
shenandoans are going on man this guy is
a [ __ ] fouchy was right like that's i
assume that that's not the case are you
talking about the case
my financial
disclosures are public knowledge and
have been so you are getting amazingly
wrong information
so
i cannot find him our office cannot find
it he can't find them so fauci must be
hiding them think about that logic where
would they be at their public knowledge
where it is totally accessible to you if
you want it for the public is it
accessible to the public
to the public right we look forward to
totally incorrect we look forward to
reviewing it it is really stunning this
guy
truly truly truly a [ __ ] and just on
his um uh political positions roger
marshall doesn't even want abortion to
be legal in cases of rape and incest
that's a moronic position to take it's
an immoral position
during covid marshall promoted
conspiracy theories that the cdc is
exaggerating covet deaths this this is
like stuff from from the you know the
cesspool of facebook facebook has even
removed marshall's posts because they
were harmful misinformation and facebook
allows tons of harmful misinformation he
was promoting uh hydro uh
hydroxychloroquine prophylactically when
it was unproven and it's since been
debunked roger marshall said i'm not
even sure that there is climate change
this guy is a [ __ ] and of course he's
in favor of repealing obamacare dr fauci
was right and unfortunately these
republicans are going to covet hearings
and asking about everything other than
actual questions about kovid if you want
to see these clips if you're just
listening today you want to see the
clips we'll have them up on our
instagram which you can find at
davidpakmanshow and you can also follow
me on instagram at david.pakman
if you're having trouble thinking of
what to give someone as a holiday gift
check out our sponsor shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering the ingredients and recipes
for craft cocktails right to your door
they send you everything you need to
make the cocktails except for the
alcohol you provide that it comes with a
really nice recipe card easy to follow
my most recent shaker and spoon cocktail
creation was called the capri crush it's
a camparian gin drink with spiced orange
grapefruit cordial and dash fire orange
bitters delicious my turned out great i
know nothing about mixing drinks neither
do most of my friends but with my shaker
and spoon cocktails i ended up looking
like i knew something about it which is
good it's very good for my cred um you
don't have to go to a crowded bar to
enjoy an excellent cocktail shaker and
spoon lets you do it all at home great
for date nights makes a perfect gift and
you'll get twenty dollars off when you
use the promo code pacman at checkout go
to shakerandspoon.com
pacman and the link is down below